Hi, my name is Reto Meier, and
I'm the tech lead for Google's
Android Developer
Relations team.
In order to minimize the battery
drain associated data
transfers, it's good practice to
use the big cookie model to
batch and bundle transfers
using sync adaptors and
eliminate unnecessary polling
with Google Cloud Messaging.
Having moved all of your
transfers into as few batches
as possible, this Dev Byte will
look at ways to reduce
the overall size of the cookie,
that is, to transfer
as little data as possible and
drain as little battery as
possible each time we do
have to do a transfer.
The most fundamental way to
reduce your downloads is to
download only what you need.
Start by using REST APIs that
let you perform filtering on
the server using parameters
that allow you to indicate
when your last update occurred
or what the last items you
received were.
This ensures that you only end
up downloading new stuff.
Similarly, it's good practice
to reduce bandwidth by
performing any operations likely
to shrink the size of
your payload on the server.
Techniques like GZIP compression
are one solution,
as is server-side reduction
of image sizes.
Why download a wallpaper, only
to shrink it into a thumbnail?
It's also generally more
efficient to maximize your
utilization of network
connections.
So rather than creating
multiple simultaneous
connections to download data,
or chaining multiple
consecutive get requests, when
possible, you should bundle
these requests into
a single get.
When it comes to cell radio
transfers, a bazooka is more
efficient than a shotgun.
It's also best practice to
reuse existing network
connections, rather than
initiating new ones.
Reusing connections also allows
the network to more
intelligently react to
congestion and related network
data issues.
Wireless radios need to be
active to transmit the
termination and termination
acknowledgement packets
associated with server
and client timeouts.
So it's also good practice to
close your connections when
they aren't in use, rather
than waiting for these
timeouts to extinguish
by themselves.
That said, closing a connection
too early can
prevent it from being reused,
which then requires additional
overhead for establishing
a new connection.
A useful compromise is to
not close the connection
immediately but to still
close it before the
inherent timeout expires.
Finally, cache aggressively.
You can maintain a cache in
shared storage within the
external cache directory or
manage a smaller cache in your
application sandbox.
Anything stored in the external
cache can be deleted
by the system if it's running
low on space, whereas you are
responsible for managing
the data stored in your
application cache.
In a lot of cases, you can
determine when you should
perform your next update by
inspecting the HTTP response
headers of your downloads.
This is particularly useful
for the static, or almost
static, resources like images.
Looking at the header response,
you can determine
the time the downloaded data was
changed and when it will
expire, allowing you to schedule
your cache refreshes
accordingly.
To make your life easier,
Android 4.0 introduced a HTTP
response cache to the HTTP URL
connection class that handles
this caching for you, inspecting
headers and
contacting the server only when
cache is expired or data
doesn't exist locally.
Throughout this series of Dev
Bytes on efficient data
transfers, we've explored how
the cell radio works and how
its state machine can
affect the battery
efficiency of your apps.
Armed with that knowledge, you
learned to analyze your
network traffic and use
techniques like prefetching,
batching, and bundling,
supported by sync adapters and
Google Cloud Messaging, to make
your apps more efficient.